what is story therapy story therapy is
something that I developed with the
recognition with how psychology and
story are so connected whether it's the
psychology of the writer the psychology
of the protagonist or the psychology of
the audience it is all about the
transformation that happens so it's
therapeutic so story therapy was a term
that came to me with the recognition I
knew about narrative therapy that was
something that I studied when I was
taking a deep dive into looking at story
from all sides I'm all about the idea of
how do we draw from meditation how do we
draw from spiritual books how do we look
at he healing books that
help writers that help us also take a
deep dive into the psychology of the
character through looking at a wound
that didn't heal in the past
that is creating a block in the present
and preventing the character from
hitting the dream in the future
so the recognition of this was that
through the pursuit if the pursuit is an
opportunity for the character to
become aware of the flaw that is holding
them back and an opportunity for them to
go one step toward healing that earlier
wound then we get how the story is
therapy
does the viewer also become healed
it's interesting
we just watched a show by Abby Morgan
called the split on Hulu and it's
interesting that you say that because
when I was an executive at spelling
television
I went through my parents divorce after
25 years then I went through a divorce
myself so I was in this bubble of
of pain and of hurt and I remember going
to the president of spelling and saying
we should do a show on divorce this is
something that would help the audience
heal this is something that 50 of the us
is going through and if they're not
going through it then they their family
is going through it or they know it
through their friends so the audience is
massive and at that point so many shows
dealt with divorce but they did surface
level and the split by Abby Morgan
takes a much deeper dive into divorce
where I felt like being in a committed
relationship and watching three seasons
of the split was amazing in that it
brought up questions for couples to ask
each other
by showing through the character
transformation
of what if somebody has a secret that
could get in the way of the marriage and
the idea of through a family law firm
you have Hannah who is a sought after
divorce attorney and then you she has
two sisters and a single mom that raised
them we find in the series Arc that the
father returns after a 30-year absence
so you have three characters who have
the same wound you're going through the
main worldview of Hannah and Hannah has
a secret and this secret could shatter
her marriage and the secret also
involves a love triangle which is
another great thing for writers to
recognize when we look at love triangles
and you see that the love triangle makes
the audience die to know what the answer
is and to know which direction which
leads from dilemma as well that the
character is gonna go in so yes I
believe that story is therapy that can
heal the audience
and for those of us who are latchkey
kids myself included watching Kramer
versus Cramer yes as a as a young person
was definitely
um probably I was too young to be
watching it but that was one that you
could identify with if you were in a
situation like that and it stayed with
you like Kramer versus Kramer stayed
with you you forever remembered like I
in my mind immediately go to that scene
by the toaster where you know where he
is unfamiliar in this space with this
child and suddenly has to learn
something and you immediately feel the
vulnerability and it helps you
understand the transformation and then
when you're in it that type of pain
which could go into
everybody's biggest fear who's ever been
in love is what is the consequence of
loving deeply and that is the idea of
the breakup the idea of the split and
and so when you create story like Kramer
versus Kramer and and the split which
was shocking to me that I had never
heard about this show and yet this
writer Abby Morgan wrote a show called
river that I explored that was also
brilliant so it it when I find shows
like these I love exposing people to
them and telling people about them so
that they can find them because it's all
about right now as an audience member
looking for a story that speaks to us a
story that we know what the writer is
trying to say through the concept and
how the central character feels about
the concept in terms of the main
conflict
what is the creative concept within a
story
the creative concept could go into the
intention of the writer when you look at
things like
the external concept the plot versus the
internal concept having to do with the
character transformation and what the
character has to learn and the creative
concept of how does one uniquely affect
the other for example when you look at a
show
like Ted lasso I look at a show like Ted
lasso and I think oh my gosh the
Brilliance of taking a show and
grounding it with the idea of two people
who
uh have to figure out how to move
forward when a marriage doesn't work
and then you add the external plot of a
U.S football coach being brought over to
London to teach I mean to coach a
Premier League soccer team
brilliant because you look at and you go
story is going to come in first you have
the agenda of Rebecca who her motives
for bringing Ted lasso over are more
antagonistic however seeing the
transformation between their Dynamic and
two people who have parallel life
traumas that are going on and then you
add a soccer team where story is coming
in and then you also add an amazing flaw
with optimism and the idea of someone
who is overly optimistic getting in the
way and then you thrust them into the
British audience where this character is
considered a wanker because he doesn't
have the skill set and that's where
growth happens so that goes into the
idea of a creative concept where the
external and the end internal are
working